monsieur le président monsieur président
de la commission des lois
madame la rapporteure mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
j'avais pris l'engagement devant vous
dès le 21 janvier de poursuivre à vos
côtés le travail normatif pour renforcer
l'ensemble des règles pour renforcer
ensemble la protection des mineurs
victimes de violences sexuelles
c'est désormais chose faite en faisant
prospérer l'initiative sénatoriales le
gouvernement a fait le choix de saisir
votre main tendue mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs pour dépasser les clivages
sur un sujet qui nécessite notre
mobilisation collective pour progresser
dans les solutions que nous pouvions
apporter face à ces situations
il nous fallait conduire ensemble les
réflexions avec hauteur de vue nuancé
discernement là aussi c'est chose faite
sous l'impulsion du président de la
république nous avons pris le temps avec
mon collègue adrien taquet de consulter
largement les associations engagées au
quotidien aux côtés des victimes pour
dégager les points de consensus mais
aussi prendre en compte les nombreuses
divergences légitime trois dispositions
fondamentales se sont clairement dégagée
de nos échanges
la fixation d'un seuil d'âge à 15 ans le
renforcement de la répression de
l'inceste et enfin l'allongement de la
prescription en cas de pluralité de
victimes
nous y avons ajouté au cours des débats
parlementaires à l'assemblée nationale
la prise en compte
d'une réalité intolérable la
prostitution des plus jeunes qui
progressent malheureusement et qui doit
être combattu sans relâche
nous allons également prises en compte
les remarques que le sénat avait formulé
en janvier pour mieux réprimer tous les
actes bucco-génitaux subi ou imposer ce
sont donc au total 5 avancée
incontestable que porte cette
proposition de loi
ces évolutions majeures sont de plus je
le crois respectueuse de notre état de
droit et en particulier des exigences
constitutionnelles de proportionnalité
et d'égalité devant la loi pénale c'est
ainsi que le 5 mars dernier l'assemblée
nationale a adopté à l'unanimité ces
avancées historiques
je veux ainsi souligné la qualité des
travaux menés par l'ensemble des
parlementaires en saluant en particulier
l'implication tout à fait remarquable
des rapporteurs
madame la députée alexandra louis à
l'assemblée nationale et bien sûr vous
même
madame la sénatrice marie mercier le
dialogue que nous avons pu instaurer
grâce à vous ainsi qu'aux présidents
buffet que je tiens à saluer également a
été essentiel dans la construction de la
version du texte dont nous débattons
aujourd'hui permettez moi également
d'avoir un mot tout à fait particulier
pour l'auteur de cette proposition de
loi
la présidente annick billon dont
l'engagement nous a lui aussi permis
d'être réunis ici aujourd'hui je me
désole et je le dis de la façon la plus
solennelle de la campagne de
désinformation pour ne pas dire plus
dont vous avez pu faire l'objet madame
la sénatrice au mépris total du travail
mené et des avancées réalisées
je tiens donc madame la sénatrice dans
cet hémicycle
et en ce moment important à vous
adresser mes remerciements et à vous
apporter non plus
leur soutien je le sais et je l' ai déjà
dit si le sujet qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui suscite les passions et sans
doute beaucoup d'émotion légitime cette
passion et cette émotion ne peuvent
qu'en matière pénale être notre seul
guide
la passion et l'émotion sont souvent
mauvaises conseillères comme en
témoignent eux les suggestions de toutes
sortes visant à renverser la charge de
la preuve et pourquoi pas prévoir les
peines plus lourdes de que pour le
meurtre et pourquoi pas ou encore l'
imprescriptibilité de ces faits et
pourquoi pas là encore je le dis
solennellement il est de notre devoir
d'aborder cette question en
responsabilité pour que la réponse
juridique soit à la hauteur de la tante
des victimes que nous savons grande mais
rien ne serait pire que de les recevoir
dans un dispositif de les décevoir par
un dispositif bancals ou même contraire
à notre constitution
c'est pourquoi je me félicite que votre
commission des lois et voter en
conscience
ces avancées historiques tout en
poursuivant le travail d'enrichissement
du texte
je ne doute d'ailleurs pas que la
poursuite de nos débats nous permettra
d'aboutir sur les tous derniers points
restant encore en discussion le travail
de pédagogie en direction nos
concitoyens est immense c'est pourquoi
il nous faut être concret quels seront
les effets de ce texte dans notre droit
pénal
comment va-t-il renforcer la protection
des enfants face aux violences sexuelles
commises par des adultes
c'est à ces questions qu'il nous faut
bien sûr répondre clairement
tout d'abord aucun adulte ne pourra se
prévaloir du consentement d'un mineur de
moins de 15 ans le texte propose
d'ajouter des nouvelles définitions au
crime de viol et au délit d'agression
sexuelle permettant d'exclure du débat
judiciaire la question du consentement
du mineur
je les dis nos exigences
constitutionnelles doivent être prises
en compte c'est pourquoi il nous faut
garantir la proportionnalité de la
répression qui tend vers une
criminalisation automatique des
nombreuses situations
c'est l'écart d'âge de 5 ans qui permet
de protéger les amours adolescentes
parce que qu'on le veuille ou non nous
avez 100 ans ont une sexualité parce que
c'est la vie parce que c'est leur vie ne
devenons pas les censeurs de leur vie
sentimentale
j'ai entendu les débats houleux et
peut-être mal informé qui sont nées
autour de cet écart d'âge mais là encore
il nous faut être clair l'instauration
de cet écart d'âge n'a pas pour objet et
ne saurait avoir pour effet de protéger
les délinquants sexuels au bénéfice de
leur jeune âge
par ailleurs tout en instaurant une loi
pénale plus forte qui en vertu de nos
principes constitutionnels ne
s'appliquera que pour l'avenir il nous
faut maintenir un niveau très élevé de
protection pour toutes les victimes de
faits commis avant l'entrée en vigueur
de cette nouvelle ainsi les dispositions
issues de la loi de 2018 continueront à
s'appliquer le viol et l'agression
sexuelle avec violence contrainte menace
ou surprise sont évidemment maintenu de
même le délit d'atteinte sexuelle ne
sera pas supprimée afin notamment de
permettre de sanctionner des faits qui
ne tomberont pas sous les nouvelles
qualifications mais aussi pour permettre
de continuer de réprimer des faits
commis avant la réforme
il n'est pas envisageable en effet de
laisser sur le bord de la route les
victimes passées les abus sexuels commis
par des majeurs et d'adopter une réforme
qui aurait pour effet d'amnistier les
auteurs de ces actes
autre avancée majeure de la proposition
de loi
les viols incestueux et les agressions
sexuelles incestueuses seront désormais
définie de manière autonome dans le code
pénal et protège pour les mineurs le
seuil d'âge est ici de 18 ans les
ascendants sont nécessairement visé par
le viol incestueux et l'agression
sexuelle incestueuse l'oncle la tante le
grand oncle la grand-tante les neveux
nièces frères soeurs conjointe de ces
derniers bons pères ou belle-mère
exerçant une autorité de fait ou de
droit sur le mineur seront évidemment
concerné pourquoi dès lors introduire la
notion d' autorité de droit ou de fait
dans le cadre des nouvelles
incriminations incestueuse parce que
nous ne pouvons pas en dehors des
ascendants automatiquement et sans
individualisation criminaliser la
relation sexuelle en raison du lien de
sang dans ces situations il nous faut
faire confiance au discernement et à
l'appréciation des situations de nos
procureurs et de nos juges voulaient
rencontrer régulièrement dans le cas de
vos travaux parlementaires vous
connaissez leurs engagements malgré la
difficulté de leur mission elles sont
confrontés tous les jours à l'indicible
aline audible et ils savent bien sûr
distinguer ce qui relève de la loi
pénale je souligne avec force devant
vous
l'avancée réalisée en matière de
relations incestueuses entre un majeur
et un mineur puisque désormais les
tribunaux n'auront plus à rechercher la
violence la contrainte la menace ou
encore la surprise
autre évolution majeure dans les
situations où un même auteur réitère des
crimes ou délits sexuels sur plusieurs
victimes
je m'étais engagé à proposer un
dispositif permettant un traitement
judiciaire
égalitaire pour toutes les victimes les
travaux normatifs nous ont conduits
instauré un régime de prescriptions
spécifiques protecteur des mineurs le
mécanisme de prescription prolongée qui
permet de faire bénéficier à toutes les
victimes de la prescription la plus
longue et un autre mécanisme que nous
mettons en place permettant
d'interrompre la prescription de tous
les crimes par la plainte de la dernière
victime
ainsi même si le dernier crime n'est
finalement pas poursuivi faute de
preuves ou s'il fait l'objet d'un
acquittement
les autres crimes révélé grâce à ce
dernier crime pourront quand même être
jugé enfin je les ai évoqué au début de
mon propos la situation des mineurs
victimes de prostitution est bien prise
en compte
désormais grâce aux nouvelles
incriminations tous majeurs de 18 ans
qui rémunère une relation sexuelle sur
un mineur de moins de 15 ans comme est
un viol puni de vingt ans ou un délit
d'agression sexuelle puni de 10 ans je
salue ici madame la rapporteure un ajout
souhaité par votre commission qui
complète la rédaction du texte
en incluant non seulement la relation
sexuelles rémunérées mais également la
promesse de rémunération la fourniture
d'un avantage en nature ou la promesse
d'un tel avantage
cet ajout permet un véritable
renforcement de la protection de nos
mineurs c'est dans ce même esprit que
votre commission a permis l'extension du
nouveau délit de ckx torsion à tous les
mineurs de 18 ans vous le voyez le texte
loin d'être un mauvais texte comme j'ai
pu le lire le texte qui vous et prénom
s'est présenté porte aujourd'hui les
avancées inédite sur de nombreux aspects
de la protection que nous devons à nos
mineurs face aux violences sexuelles y
subissent l'ambition historique qu'il
porte nous permettra de dire
solennellement aux victimes il y aura un
avant et un après cette loi
merci merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est maintenant là marie
mercier rapporteur de la commission des
lois
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
président la commission des lois
monsieur le garde des sceaux mes chers
collègues lee exactement dix jours
l'assemblée nationale a adopté à
l'unanimité une proposition de loi au
nouveau titre puisqu'elle vise à
protéger les mineurs des crimes et
délits sexuels et de l'inceste de façon
à prendre en compte les nombreuses
dispositions qui ont donc enrichi le
texte qui avait été déposé par notre
collègue annie guillon le sénat avait
également adopté à l'unanimité
après l'avoir amendé cette proposition
de loi
les votes successifs montrent que le
texte répond à une attente dans leur
grande majorité
nos concitoyens demandent un
renforcement de la protection des
mineurs contre les violences sexuelles
qui peuvent être commises par les
adultes
l'objectif essentiel est qu'il ne soit
plus nécessaire de s'interroger sur la
question du consentement des jeunes
mineurs les gars à son manque de
maturité et de discernement
rappelons-nous camion un homme ça
s'empêche il est effectivement de la
responsabilité de l'adulte de respecter
des limites pour préserver l'intégrité
physique et psychique des enfants et des
adolescents
et je crois que nous sommes tous
d'accord en première lecture nous avions
estimé que la création d'une infraction
autonome de crimes sexuels sur mineurs
heures avec un seuil d'âge fixée à 13
ans répondait à nos objectifs
il en aurait résulté une gradation dans
la protection des mineurs avec le délit
d'atteinte sexuelle puni de 7 ans
d'emprisonnement pour protéger les
mineurs de moins de 15 ans est le
nouveau crime sexuel sur mineur pour
protéger les mineurs de moins de 13 ans
et 20 ans de prison
il nous faut reconnaître cependant que
le choix d'un seuil à 13 ans
même s'il présente de solides
justification a pu être mal compris et
parfois mal perçues même comme un recul
par rapport au seuil de 15 ans qui
figure dans le délit d'atteinte sexuelle
je veux témoigner ici comme vous l'avez
fait monsieur le garde des sceaux de ma
sympathie à hannut billon qui a fait
l'objet dans les jours qui ont suivi
l'adoption du texte au sénat d' attaques
inacceptables sur les réseaux sociaux
avec l'appui de la chancellerie semblait
nationale imaginez une solution
différente qui tient compte de nos
préoccupations
tout en étant mieux comprise par les
associations de protection de l'enfance
comme les auditions auxquelles j'ai
procédé ont pu nous le montrer dans le
texte qui nous est transmis le seuil
d'âge est fixée à 15 ans mais il est
assorti d'un écart d'âge de 5 entre
l'auteur des faits et la victime de
cette manière les relations consenties
entre un mineur d'un peu moins de 15 ans
et un tout jeune majeur relations qui
ont d'ailleurs pu débuter alors que les
deux partenaires étaient mineurs ne
seront pas automatiquement criminalisés
c'est le mot automatique qui est
important dans cette phrase le choix de
créer une infraction autonome avait
également suscité des réserves à
certains lui reprochant d'évacuer la
dimension violente du passage à l'acte
qui serait mieux prises en compte avec
la qualification de viol ou d'agression
sexuelle sur ce point également
l'assemblée nationale a fait preuve
d'esprit de synthèse en décidant de
qualifier de viol la nouvelle infraction
sur miller je tiens à dire que certaines
infractions prévues par le code pénal
renvoie à plusieurs définitions
c'est le cas par exemple pour le
harcèlement sexuel qui suppose en
principe la commission d'actes répétés
mais qui peut aussi être constituée si
un acte unique particulièrement grave a
été commis donc tel serait désormais le
cas pour le crime de viol à la
définition classique
qui suppose un élément de contrainte
menaces violences ou surprise
s'ajouterait une nouvelle définition
applicable seulement si la victime est
un mineur de 15 ans concernant la
définition du viol je signale que
l'assemblée nationale a conservé la
modification que le sénat l'a adopté sur
proposition de nos collègues
esther benbassa et laurence rossignol
tendant à élargir aux actes bucco
génitaux il s'agit là d'une avancée
importante ces actes pouvant être aussi
traumatisant pour la victime qu'une
pénétration sexuelle sur la question de
l'inceste le texte renforce la
protection de tous les mineurs jusqu'à
18 ans en introduisant douze infractions
de crise insiste feu et d'agressions
sexuelles incestueuses qui seront
constitués si les faits sont commis par
un ascendant ou par un membre de la
famille ayant une autorité de droit ou
de fait sur la victime par membre de la
famille fond tendent les frères et
soeurs oncles et tantes neveux et nièces
ainsi que leur conjoint concubin ou
partenaire de pacs
l'assemblée nationale a souhaité ajouter
à cette liste les grands oncles et les
grands tantes
je sais que l'exigence d'une autorité de
droit ou de fait a pu susciter des
interrogations
après réflexion je suis arrivé à la
conclusion qu'il s'agit d'un critère
essentiel à la cohérence d'ensemble du
dispositif
en effet en l'absence d'une relation
d'autorité comment distinguer l'auteur
des faits de la victime certains diront
que le partenaire majeur est forcément
coupable mais cette affirmation ne
résiste pas à un examen objectif de la
diversité des situations qui peuvent se
rencontrer sur le terrain
par exemple dans une famille un fils de
17 ans peuvent fort bien avoir
l'ascendant sur le reste de la fratrie
compris sur sa soeur de 18 ans et demi
si le père est absent et il arrive même
parfois que le fils aîné se comporte
quasiment chef de famille en cas de
relation incestueuse
il convient donc d'examiner chaque
situation au cas par cas et c'est le
rôle du juge afin de déterminer qui a
implosé l'acte sexuel sans quoi nous
exposerions à un risque élevé d'erreurs
judiciaires
j'en arrive à la question un peu
complexe de la prescription pour vous
indiquer d'abord que l'assemblée
nationale
à conserver l'allongement du délai de
prescription pour le délit de non
dénonciation d'infractions sur mineur
que le sénat avait adopté en le
recentrant sur les crimes et délits
sexuels
ce qui est cohérent avec l'objet du
texte en ce qui concerne la prescription
des crimes et délits sexuels eux-mêmes
l'assemblée nationale a adopté sur
proposition du gouvernement
un double mécanisme donc le premier
s'inspire de celui introduit par le
sénat
il aurait pour effet de prolonger le
délai de prescription d'un crime ou
délit sexuel sur mineur si l'auteur
comme et un autre crime aux délits
sexuels sur un autre mineur le deuxième
n'est kahnisme s'inspire de la notion de
connexité un acte interruptif de
prescription une audition par exemple
interrompre et la prescription
non seulement dans la sphère considérer
mais également dans les autres
procédures dans lesquelles serait
reproché au même auteur la commission
d'un autre crime ou délit sexuel sur
mineur avec ces deux dispositifs toutes
les victimes pourront comparaître comme
tel devant la cour d'assises alors
qu'aujourd'hui les victimes les plus
anciennes dont les faits sont prescrits
sont seulement entendu en tant que
témoin je sais que le garde des sceaux
fort de sa longue expérience d'avocats
pénalistes et sensible cette évolution
que notre commission a approuvé
j'évoquerai enfin les autres
dispositions qui figure dans le texte
tout d'abord l'assemblée nationale a
conservé les mesures à caractère
préventif que nous avions adopté à
l'initiative de michel savin et valérie
boyer elles tendent à élargir la liste
des inscriptions entraînant une
inscription au fichier s est elle incite
les érudits les juridictions a prononcé
la peine complémentaire d'interdiction
d'exercer une activité impliquant un
contact habituel avec les mineurs
l'assemblée nationale a enrichi le texte
à l'initiative de la rapporteure
alexandra louis de manière à mieux
réprimer des phénomènes nouveaux apparus
sur internet et je dois dire très
inquiétant par l'équipe des majeurs
demande à des mineurs d'accomplir des
actes obscènes devant une caméra en leur
demandant de se filer a1 a2 a3 et puis
de renvoyer les images parfois qualifiée
de ckx torsion ces agissements peuvent
rouvrir la voie à un véritable chantage
exercé sur le mineur
pour l'amener à accomplir des actes de
plus en plus avilissant je vous propose
d'approuver ces dispositions nouvelles
afin que la loi pénale exprime
clairement notre refus de ce type de
comportement au total le texte ce qui
vous est soumis en force vraiment la
protection des mineurs au prix il est
vrai d'une plus grande complexité des
règles de droit applicables
un travail de pédagogie devrait être
mené par la chancellerie auprès des
juridictions et je souhaite que nous
puissions après l'adoption de ce texte
stabiliser les règles applicables aux
infractions sexuelles sur mineures afin
que les professionnels du droit et le
temps de se les approprier
ce texte donne des outils aux juges avec
le but que nous partageons tous de
diminuer le nombre de jugements de
classement sans suite le regard du juge
évolue aussi avec la société la
commission vous propose de préserver les
grands équilibres du texte
certes il n'est pas parfait mais je suis
convaincu qu'il marquera une étape
importante dans nos politiques de
sauvegarde de l'enfance il faudra bien
sûr l'accompagner de mesures de
prévention et d'éducation dans les
écoles dans les milieux sportifs dans
lisation et surtout dans les familles
ces mesures ne relève pas du domaine de
la loi mais elles sont décisives pour
préserver les enfants et les adolescents
contre les violences sexuelles
je suis convaincu aussi que ce n'est pas
la loi qu'il suffit de changer mais que
ce sont les mentalités qui doivent
évoluer
vraiment nous devons préserver nos
enfants les enfants ils ne doivent pas
être chaque âge saccagé les enfants il
faut que tous ensemble nous soyons là
pour préserver leurs rêves je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
la discussion générale
la parole est à stéphane ravier pour 3
minutes
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues à
l'exception de quelques soixante
huitards qui ne se sent rien n'interdit
même pas des rapports sexuels avec des
mineurs
nous verrons qui continue à bénéficier
vous devez relever le masque sur le nez
sur c'est un roc c'est une péninsule
monsieur le président c'est pour ça que
le masque baisse un peu je reprends donc
à l'exception de quelques 68 ans qui ne
se sont rien n'interdit même pas les
rapports sexuels avec des mineurs et qui
continue à bénéficier d'une certaine et
nauséabonde bienveillance médiatique
voici un texte avec lequel on semble les
français seront d'accord protéger les
mineurs des crimes et délits sexuels et
de l'inceste
cependant nous avons fait nous avons
fait l'expérience le sénat a été pris
pour cible à l'issue de la première
lecture par une certaine presse qui a
relayé à grand renfort de titres
raccourci les intentions contraire à
celle que nous avions souhaité donner à
ce texte
quel était le but de cette campagne est
sinon de désinformation à tout le moins
de déformation déstabiliser le sénat
sans qualités de contre-pouvoirs
démocratiques décrédibiliser
l'initiative parlementaire des élus
représentant les territoires ce qui est
certain c'est que les français sont à
cran en témoignent de l'ampleur prise et
dans l'opinion par le vote à l'unanimité
de ce texte
je veux donc dire ici mes chers
collègues pour que nos collègues
conclusions soient claires je veux
surtout le dire à ceux qui suivent nos
travaux aux victimes qui attendent
beaucoup de la protection de la loi
ainsi qu'aux parents qui craignent pour
la sécurité de leurs enfants
non le sénat n'a pas baissé la majorité
sexuelle à 13 ans oui
le sénat votera chez tex et j'espère à
l'unanimité nous continuerons de faire
évoluer notre droit pour que les
personnes se rendant coupables de viol
viol sur mineure viol incestueux
harcèlement malgré son agression
sexuelle atteinte sexuelle d'autres
circonstances aggravantes soient
poursuivis et sévèrement punis et pour
cela il convient de rappeler que le
coeur de cette proposition de loi est la
création d'un nouveau crime sexuel sur
mineur de moins de 15 ans mais elle
permet aussi après évolution
l'élargissement de la définition du viol
et du crime sexuel sur mineur
l'allongement des délais de prescription
elle crée aussi de
l'infraction de viol institut incestueux
et d'agressions sexuelles incestueuses
enfin l'élargissement de la liste des
infractions entraînant l'inscription au
fichier judiciaire des auteurs
d'infractions sexuelles violentes
alors mes chers collègues je vous
appelle à être consciencieux ne manquons
pas de cohérence et de lisibilité
il faut une loi compréhensibles par tous
qui ne soit pas interprétable par tous
les complices et de la buvette de
l'abject qui essaient encore de salir de
blessés de viol et psychologiquement par
les écrits odieux qu'ils ont encore
l'opportunité de publier
sachant rédiger un interdit clair autant
que nous devons voter des peines sévères
exemplaire à la hauteur de l'ignominie
que constituent les actes que paie le
criminel à la hauteur des attentes des
victimes et de leurs familles bien merci
chers collègues la parole est à notre
collègue vanina paolig agents pour 4
minutes ch monsieur le président
monsieur le garde des sceaux
mes chers collègues nous nous réunissons
à nouveau aujourd'hui pour garantir à
nos enfants une meilleure protection
contre les violences sexuelles depuis
trop longtemps
nous constatons le décalage entre la
réalité des violences faites aux enfants
et le regard que portent les
institutions mais aussi une partie de la
société sur ces violences
longtemps nous avons proposé aux
victimes une alternative inadéquate soit
le silence soit des réponses à la fois
un complète en matière d'accompagnement
et complexe au plan judiciaire
c'est pourquoi je me résume je me
réjouis que des étapes importantes
étaient franchies au cours de ces
dernières années
désormais bien plus que hier on écoute
les victimes on les croit on les aide
toutefois si la loi du 3 août 2010 8
renforçant la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes a déjà permis des
avancées majeures
il nous faut aller plus loin encore pour
que les choses soient désormais clair
pour toutes et tous on ne touche pas à
une naissance des enfants
la proposition de loi déposée par notre
collègue yannick billon 5,5 ce cri dans
l'esprit de très nombreux travaux
parlementaires déjà mené avec engagement
au sénat et tente de répondre un
terrifiant constat 80 % environ des
violences commencé avant 18 ans la
première agression survenue en moyenne à
l'âge de 9 ans dans plus de 90% des cas
elles sont commises par des proches
aussi je me félicite que l'assemblée
nationale ait souhaité contribuer à
améliorer la protection des mineurs
contre ces violences notre commission a
travaillé à parfaire les équilibres qui
ont pu être trouvé il était
indispensable de préserver celui de
l'échelle des peines
il était aussi nécessaire de procéder à
plusieurs ajustements notamment en
créant de nouvelles circonstances
aggravantes
ce texte durcit également les sanctions
de l'inceste et prévoit l'interruption
de plusieurs délais de prescription
ce faisant la proposition de loi que
nous examinons rempli deux objectifs
elle améliore d'abord la protection des
victimes
elle envoie ensuite un message clair et
fort en rappelant à tous les adultes la
nécessité de protéger nos enfants
si les mineurs de moins de 15 ans sont
particulièrement vulnérables
nous considérons que les mineurs dans
leur ensemble sont des personnes
vulnérables à qui nous devons une
protection accrue
nous nous réjouissons donc que la
rédaction des nouveaux délits de ce
extorsion sur internet était et modifié
en ce sens et protège à présent tous les
mineurs avant de conclure je tiens à
remercier annie billon auteurs de cette
proposition de loi qui consacre un
combat de plusieurs années mais aussi
marie mercier pour son engagement sur ce
sujet et la qualité de ses travaux
enfin j'ai une pensée pour toutes les
victimes dont certaines nous écoute peut
être aujourd'hui monsieur le garde des
sceaux
mes chers collègues le groupe les
indépendants soutient cette proposition
de loi
en espérant qu'après les nombreuses
discussions qui ont déjà eu lieu sur ce
sujet au sein de notre assemblée ce
texte recueillera un accord trans
partisan est que ces dispositions sur
tout
s'appliqueront le plus rapidement
possible je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
désormais à madame esther benbassa pour
le groupe écologie solidarité territoire
pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre adama à porter chers collègues
la nouvelle lecture de cette proposition
de loi qui nous devons d'abord il
convient de le rappeler à notre chère
collègue annie quillon que j'ai sali et
la démonstration parfaite des progrès
sociétaux qui pernette d'un travail
commun et trans partisan entre les deux
assemblées
le gens c'était indéniable il convenait
de faire évoluer la loi pour mieux
protéger les quelques 160 mille mineurs
qui selon les estimations
si lui chacun en france des violences
sexuelles
il convenait aussi d'apporter une
réponse jst à la libération de la parole
des victimes d'inceste notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag nitoo
1,16 mais aussi avec les récentes
affaires révélées dans les médias et qui
ont ému agissent tite l'opinion publique
c'est donc en renfort de cette
initiative sénatoriale que les députés
de l'assemblée nationale ont fait les
choix qui nous saignons d'inscrire ce
texte à leur heure du jour et de
l'amendé positivement pour aboutir à
cette version qui nous convient à mon
groupe et un mot à moi même
parmi les nouveautés ici de la navette
parlementaire la réécriture de l'article
1er qui vise à sanctionner tout acte
sexuel commis par un mage
c'est une personne mineure de 15 ans et
une amélioration significative
désormais la mer pénétration ou l'acte
bucco-génitales commis par un majeur sur
une personne de moins de 15 ans sera
qualifiée de vol
le relèvement de ce seuil de 13 ans à 15
ans était une demande de certaines
d'entre nous et d'ailleurs toutes les
sénatrices du groupe écologie solidarité
territoire auquel j'appartiens avait
cosigné en première lecture
l'amendement déposé en ce sens par
madame la présidente
rossignol nous nous satisfaisons
également du renforcement vie dispositif
d'interruption du délai de prescription
en cas de commission d'un même crime par
un même auteur
à l'endroit d'autres mineurs nous nous
félicitons en outre que le rapport du
coup j'ai du talent soit reconnu comme
violent au même titre que la pénétration
sexuelle
mon groupe avait notamment été à
l'initiative de l'amendement qui
allaient dans ce sens enfin surtout nous
nous réjouissons que la france est
finalement le courage de reconnaître
dans son droit
l'inceste comme crime en soi la version
ici de l'assemblée introduit une
nouvelle infraction qui est le viol
ainsi cieux l'inceste dans notre pays et
tim réalité que nous ne pouvions plus
ignorer comme près de 6,7 millions de
françaises et français auraient été
victimes d'inceste
selon une étude menée par l'association
face à l'inceste
il revient maintenant à l'état de se
pencher plus encore sur le sujet et de
produits régulièrement des données
officielles précises qui permettront de
prendre toute l'ampleur de l'année
lité des violences sexuelles commises
sur les personnes mineures
cette proposition de loi nous semble
protectrice elle constitue une vraie
avancée sociétale
le groupe écologie solidarité territoire
votera pour ses textes merci merci chers
collègues et la parole est désormais à
notre collègue xavier iacovelli pour le
groupe air des pays pour quatre minutes
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
madame le rapporteur chers collègues
nous examinons aujourd'hui en deuxième
lecture la proposition de loi de notre
collègue annie billon visant à mieux
protéger les mineurs des crimes sexuels
le 21 janvier dernier nous adoptions à
l'unanimité ce texte qui prévoyait
initialement d'introduire au sein du
code pénal un nouveau crime autonome
puni de vingt ans de réclusion
criminelle est caractérisée par tout
acte de pénétration sexuelle de quelque
nature qu'il soit commis par un majeur
sur un mineur de moins de 13 ans pour la
première fois au delà des clivages qui
traversent notre assemblée nous
inscrivions dans la loi un seuil d'âge
des mon consentement 13 ans à l'origine
afin de criminaliser tout acte de
pénétration sexuelle commis par un
adulte assure un enfant cette ppl a fait
l'objet de modifications importantes
lors de son examen à l'assemblée
nationale et nous tenons à saluer nous
avons tous à l'esprit les innombrables
témoignages de personnalités publiques
ou d'anonymes qui ont contribué à lever
le tabou autour de l'inceste est enfin
libéré la parole des victimes en y
intégrant un crime de viol incestueux et
un délit d'agression sexuelle
incestueuse
ce texte met fin à des lacunes de la loi
sur ses actes et un autre aveuglement
collectif sur ce que vivent 10 % des
enfants bien souvent livrés à eux-mêmes
et contraint au silence
en vertu de cette proposition loi
l'inceste constitue désormais une
infraction spécifique assorties de
sanctions propre et non plus uniquement
une sur qualification pénale
tous les mineurs jusqu'à 18 ans seraient
protégés par ces nouvelles dispositions
je m'en réjouis car non il
existe pas d'inceste consentie ou
heureux il s'agit toujours d'un calvaire
qui hantent les victimes parfois tout au
long de leur vie
l'article 1er au coeur de cette
proposition de loi a donc été réécrit un
interdit est désormais posée à 15 ans ce
qui conduit à ne plus interrogé le
consentement du mineur en dessous de cet
âge il s'agit ici d'une avancée majeure
unanimement salué cet exposé un principe
clair en dessous de 15 ans ces nombres
il était toutefois nécessaire d'apporter
un aménagement pour éviter de
criminaliser les amours adolescentes qui
existe et nous le savons continueront
d'exister dans notre société
ce texte prévoit donc désormais quatre
infractions nouvelle qui nécessitent pas
d'établir une violence contrainte menace
ou surprise allant ainsi dans le sens
d'une meilleure protection des mineurs
cet enrichissement saluée par tous
démontre la capacité de nos assemblées à
surmonter ces oppositions lorsque
l'intérêt général et surtout celui de
nos enfants est en jeu
nous allons également la création par
voie d'amendement du délit de ce
extorsion lorsqu'un majeur un site un
mineur sur les réseaux sociaux à
commettre un acte de nature sexuelle sur
lui même ou sur un tiers y compris si
cette provocation n'est pas suivi ce
nouveau délit temps à prendre en compte
l'évolution des rapports et l'appétence
des jeunes parfois des très jeunes pour
les réseaux sociaux grâce à ce délit de
ces extorsions le droit s'adapte à
l'apparition de nouvelles formes de
criminalité en ligne dans les mineures
sont victimes et qui conduisent bien
souvent des drames
enfin cette proposition loi crée un
mécanisme de prescription prolongée dans
le cadre des crimes sériels sur
proposition du garde des sceaux un
deuxième mécanisme a été introduit
visant à ce qu'un acte interruptif de
prescription puisse prendre effet non
seulement dans la sphère considérer mais
également dans les autres procédures
dans lesquelles serait reproché au même
auteur la commission d'un autre crime ou
délit sur mineurs à titre personnel je
souhaite que nous ayons un débat sur
l'existence même du délai de
prescription pour les actes sexuels
commis sur des mineurs
pour conclure je tiens à saluer le
travail de notre collègue annick billon
qui par l'adoption je l'espère de ce
texte aboutira à une meilleure
protection des mineurs remercie
également le rapporteur marie mercier
dont les amendements
me le rend fort c'est juridiquement
cette ppl remercier enfin le
gouvernement pour les concertations
qu'il avait annoncé dans notre hémicycle
et qui ont été menées pour faire évoluer
ce texte
pour ces raisons le groupe r des pays
soutiendra et votera en faveur de cette
proposition de loi est bien merci chers
collègues la parole est désormais à
notre collègue maryse carrère pour le
groupe rdse pour 4 minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux madame la rapporteure
mes chers collègues
permettez moi chers collègues avant de
commencer quelques jours du début de
l'examen du texte des respects sur les
respect des principes de la république
d'apporter tout le soutien du groupe
rdse à la présidente carole delga et nos
collègues conseillers régionaux
d'occitanie qui ont subi cet après midi
durant leur séance plénière à toulouse
il ne violente intrusion par des
extrémistes d'actions françaises nous
condamnons avec fermeté cette atteinte
au fonctionnement d'une institution de
notre république est symboliquement à
notre démocratie
pour en revenir à ce texte
au mois de janvier dernier le sénat a
adopté à l'unanimité cette proposition
visant à instituer une nouvelle
incrimination pénale de crimes sexuels
sur mineurs le groupe rdse et moi même
tenons à redire tout notre soutien
pour l'auteur de cette proposition de
loi annick billon victimes à l'époque
d'une polémique et d'un traitement
médiatique injuste et regrettable elle
aura eu le mérite de remettre l'ouvragé
sur le métier et d'engager à nouveau le
parlement dans un travail visant à
proposer un meilleur dispositif de
condamnation des auteurs de violences
sexuelles sur mineures d'une part et
d'autre part à enfin pouvoir institué
une véritable condamnation pénale de
l'unss est désormais le nouveau texte
comprendre ce que beaucoup avaient
appelé de leurs souhaits la condamnation
des crimes sexuels sur les mineurs de
moins de 15 ans il faut le redire
en aucun cas le sénat avait adopté en
première lecture une loi autorisant les
relations sexuelles entre majeurs et un
mineur à partir de 13 ans au contraire
le dispositif voté venez renforcer la
protection des enfants
ainsi grâce à l'apport de l'assemblée
nationale ce renforcement bénéficiera
également aux enfants de 13 à 15 ans
jusqu'à cet âge il ne sera donc plus
nécessaire de rechercher l'existence
d'un consentement chez l'enfant qui
justifierait l'acte de l'adulte sur la
question de l'inceste ensuite
déjà en 2019 notre ancien collègue
françoise laborde avait été à l'origine
d'une proposition de résolution pour
intensifier la lutte et la prévention
contre l'inceste
il y a lieu de se réjouir que les choses
avancent
certes lors de nos débats en première
lecture nous avions buté sur des
difficultés d'ordre juridique quand bien
même la condamnation de l'inceste dans
son principe ne s'ouvre le soulever
patte de difficultés mais l'assemblée
nationale a pu poursuivre nos travaux et
proposer un texte satisfaisant même s'il
n'est pas parfait qui pourrait mettre
fin à une anomalie qui existe depuis
trop longtemps dans notre droit
l'absence d'infraction spécifique à
l'inceste
parmi les autres innovations apportées
au texte initial
il faut aussi souligner celle qui vise à
sanctionner plus durement les prédateurs
qui utilisent internet pour forcer les
mineurs accomplir sur eux mêmes les
actes les plus dégradants il s'agit ici
aussi d'un fléau qui peut briser
durablement la vie de certains enfants
et auquel nous devons aussi apporter une
réponse pénale et c'est quelque chose
qui tient à coeur à notre rapporteur que
je salue et je remercie aussi son
travail sur ce texte
enfin nous observons une actualité
médiatique qui révèle de plus en plus
régulièrement des affaires de violences
sexuelles sur mineurs face à ces faits
nous devons apprendre à mieux recevoir
la parole des enfants victimes à
faciliter leur accompagnement dans sa
dimension judiciaire certes mais
également dans sa dimension humaine et
sociale
il faut qu'il n'y ait aucun doute pour
les victimes de ces abus qu'elles seront
soutenus par notre nation dans cette
perspective j'aimerais me réjouir que
malgré certains événements la commission
indépendante sur les violences sexuelles
sur mineurs et été maintenue il a fallu
qu'elle soit recomposée mais il est
certain que ces travaux participeront à
nous éclairer sur un sujet complexe et
difficile mais également fondamental
aussi en conclusion je reprendrai
l'avertissement de l'un des nouveaux
membres de la commission le thérapeute
écrivain jean paul meunier
ils disent je le cite ne détournons pas
de nouveau notre regard de celui des
enfants qui désespéraient tente de nous
faire savoir le mal dont ils sont les
victimes
il écrivait déjà ses mots en 1999 il y à
déjà plus de 20 ans cela doit nous faire
réaliser combien il y aura fallu de
temps pour que les choses avancent
significativement vous comprendrez donc
à l'unanimité
le groupe rdse votera en faveur de cette
proposition de loi
merci merci chers collègues
la parole est désormais à laurence cohen
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologistes
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux mes chers collègues après
notre travail en première lecture sur la
ppl présenté par notre collègue annick
billon que je tiens une nouvelle fois
remercier ce nouveau rendez-vous pour
parfaire la protection des mineurs des
crimes et délits sexuels était très
attendue d'autant que le travail du
sénat avait fait naître une polémique
injustifiée dans les médias du fait
d'une interprétation erronée les tabous
sont levés la cause des enfants victimes
de ces violences sexistes brise fort
justement le mur du silence
c'est notamment grâce aux associations
de protection de l'enfance et aux
nombreuses victimes qui ont continué à
se battre
elles ont démontré à juste titre la
nécessité de faire évoluer notre droit
pour une loi plus claire marquant un
interdit sans ambiguïté et surtout sans
avoir à interroger le consentement
prétendument de la victime
l'interdît est clairement posée ici
aucun adulte n'a le droit d'avoir des
rapports sexuels avec un ou une enfant
fixation d'un seuil de 15 ans repoussé à
18 ans pour l'inceste
c'est une bonne chose mais
malheureusement ce seuil est assortie en
dehors de l'inceste d'une condition
d'écart d'âge de 5 ans pour prendre en
compte la clause dite de roméo juliette
même si nous avons bien compris que cet
écart n'aurait plus lieu d'être dès lors
qu'un des éléments classiques du viol
serait présent nous craignons que cette
rédaction limite véritablement la portée
de cette mesure et nous fasse retomber
dans les mêmes débats autour du
consentement
en effet 65% des violeurs de mineurs ont
entre 18 et 24 ans et certaines victimes
de 14 ans par exemple seront par
conséquent moins bien protégés
devons y réfléchir par ailleurs en
première lecture non groupe avait déposé
un amendement pour compléter la
définition du viol et instaurer une
présomption de contraintes
estimant que la création d'une
infraction autonome sans jamais utiliser
le bo violent poser problème l'ajout par
l'assemblée nationale de ce terme
et parce que les mots ont un sens nous
convient si nous nous réjouissons que
les débats à l'assemblée nationale et
permet de considérer l'un cesse non plus
comme une circonstance aggravante
mais bien comme une infraction à part
entière vous proposez en quelque sorte
de le conditionnalité à la notion d'
autorité de droit ou de fait n'est ce
pas une porte ouverte pour les
agresseurs qui ne sont pas dans une
situation d' autorité de droit ou de
fait notre groupe soutient par contre
sans réserve
le nouveau délit créé pour des faits de
ce extorsion qui va plus loin que la
corruption sur mineure en s'adaptant à
la réalité d'aujourd'hui à savoir le
tout numérique et l'utilisation
d'internet
enfin nous soutenons le mécanisme créé
de prescription glissante pour permettre
la prolongation du délai de prescription
en cas de nouvelle infraction tout en
entendant les réserves du syndicat de la
magistrature sur l'imprescribilité du
fait de fête pardon au final ce texte
crée de nouvelles infractions allant du
crime au délit pour essayer de couvrir
un champ très large mais attention
attention à la complexité de tous ces
dispositifs
le principe de lisibilité de la loi est
ainsi sérieusement écornée il nous faut
bien en mesurer les conséquences
mes chers collègues ce texte est
important il est le fruit d'un long
travail et notamment celui de marie
mercier que je veux saluer un travail
collectif pour améliorer ses définition
du viol et de l'agression sexuelle qui
ne pouvaient être les mêmes quand on
parle de mineurs je regrette néanmoins
que tout en apportant de belles avancées
ils affaiblissent parfois la portée du
texte initial en créant des dérogations
de même je m'interroge sur la
temporalité qui va pouvoir exister avec
le travail sur l'inceste de la
commission indépendante
co présidée par édouard durand ou celui
du groupe de travail contre la
prostitution des mineurs mes chers
collègues je crois qu'au delà du
répressif et du suivi des eaux
heures nous devons nous interroger sur
le rapport de notre société à ce
phénomène des violences faites aux
enfants
agir sur les mentalités par l'éducation
la déconstruction des stéréotypes
sexistes c'est une urgence
nous devons également prendre le temps
d'évaluer les politiques qui sont mises
en place
judiciaire mais pas seulement je pense
notamment à la pratique de la
correctionnalisation ou encore à
l'accueil à l'accompagnement des
victimes à la formation des
professionnels
comment ignorer que les brigades locales
de protection des mineurs sont en
souffrance en termes d'effectifs et de
moyens
en attendant cette loi est une étape
importante dans la lutte pour protéger
les enfants contre les délits et crimes
sexuels mais il reste encore beaucoup de
chemin à parcourir
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est désormais notre collègue
annick guillou monsieur le président
monsieur le garde des sceaux merci pour
vos mots monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
madame la rapporteure merci chers
l'arrêt mes chers collègues nous sommes
à nouveau réunis aujourd'hui pour
examiner ma proposition de loi modifié
qui intègre désormais les crimes et
délits incestueux le 21 janvier dernier
le sénat inscrivait pour la première
fois dans la loi un solide âge de non
consentement à 13 ans l'inadaptation des
critères du viol et l'impossibilité d'un
enfant à consentir à une relation
sexuelle avec un adulte
enfin reconnu la haute assemblée a ainsi
ouvert la voie en adoptant ce texte à
l'unanimité
parce qu'il est difficile d'obtenir un
tel consensus
ce vote témoigne de la capacité du sénat
à s'emparer d'un sujet trop longtemps
passé sous silence
ce texte débattu à l'assemblée nationale
le 15 mars dernier revient enrichi et
modifier grâce à un travail de co
construction du parlement avec le garde
des sceaux
je souhaite à ce titre remercier tous
ceux qui ont contribué à son
amélioration
madame la rapporteure marie mercier
la commission des lois du sénat pardon
la rapporteur de l'assemblée nationale
madame alexandra louis et les députés le
gouvernement ait enfin le groupe union
centriste et son président hervé
marseille pour avoir pris de risque d'
inscrire cette proposition de loi à
l'automne dernier à un moment où ce
sujet ne faisait pas consensus
la commission des lois du sénat par la
voix de sa rapporteure a souhaité
retoucher le texte issu de l'assemblée
nationale ces amendements n'ont pas pour
but de remettre en cause les grands
équilibres trouvés mais de nous assurer
de sa cohérence juridique
il en va de la protection des victimes
nous nous devons d'apporter une réponse
pénale ferme et adaptés à ceux qui
s'avèrent relever d'un phénomène de
masse soixante pour cent des victimes de
violences sexuelles sont des enfants et
sur les trois cent mille victimes de
viol chaque année seuls 0,3 pour cent
des violeurs sont condamnés pendant trop
longtemps nous avons fait preuve
d'impuissance voir d'incurie pour
traiter ce fléau
notre regard sur les violences sexuelles
sur mineures spécifiquement dans le
cadre intrafamilial a été frappée de
cécité et pour cause nos sociétés ont
érigé depuis plusieurs siècles
le foyer en sanctuaire difficile alors
d'appréhender les atrocités et tous
faits qui peuvent se jouer dans le huis
clos familial
il aura fallu plusieurs étapes plusieurs
lois plusieurs ouvrages plusieurs
témoignages pour que la parole se libère
massivement mais aussi et surtout pour
que l'on entende enfin la voix de ses
enfants
à présent ces agissements seront
qualifiés et reconnus dans le code pénal
comme des infractions spécifiques
elles porteront les noms de viol sur
mineure viol incestueux agressions
sexuelles sur mineures agressions
sexuelles incestueuses nos collègues
députés ont introduit des dispositions
nouvelles sur l'inceste d'abord
désormais l'inceste est reconnue comme
une infraction spécifique et punis à
hauteur de sa gravité
lorsque la victime est mineure les
députés ont également opté pour le
relèvement du
une de 13 à 15 ans à partir duquel tout
rapport sexuel entre une personne
majeure et un mineur est un crime
j'avais initialement fait le choix de
poser cet interdit à 13 ans et de
renforcer avec la commission des lois la
protection des adolescents de 13 à 15
ans le texte voté à l'assemblée
nationale a pris une autre voie
un interdit à 15 ans avec des exceptions
afin de notamment de tenir compte des
amours adolescentes en prévoyant un
écart d'âge de 5 ans nous sommes animés
par un objectif commun celui de mieux
protéger nos enfants face aux agresseurs
sexuels et si je reconnais la portée
symbolique de ce seuil à 15 ans je reste
cependant convaincu que le dispositif
initial portait en lui les avantages de
la clarté et celui de la sécurité
juridique et constitutionnel ce
dispositif avait malheureusement été mal
compris au moment de son adoption et des
interprétations erronées abusive avait
prospéré déduisant à tort que le sénat
avait abaissé l'âge du consentement à 13
ans l'assemblée nationale est également
venu préciser l'apport du sénat en
matière de prescription
la prescription glissante proposé par le
gouvernement donnera l'opportunité à
celles et ceux qui n'ont pas pu ou pas
voulu parler de confondre leurs
agresseurs et de réhabiliter ainsi ses
victimes qui se sont murés dans le
silence
craignant que leurs paroles ne les livre
à plus de violence que de justice ce
texte apporte des avancées majeures est
attendu car il entérine un virage
décisif dans la manière d'appréhender
les violences sexuelles sur mineures à
présent un enfant ne sera plus jamais
considéré comme complice ou complaisant
vis-à-vis des actes sexuels qu'un adulte
comme est sur lui ce changement de
paradigme est fondamental dans la
reconstruction future des enfants en
reconnaissant intégralement leur qualité
de victimes la justice permettra de
retirer le poids d'une culpabilité est
prouvée à tort
chers collègues en 2018 à l'occasion du
vote sur le projet de loi visant à
lutter contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes
j'avais devant cette assemblée poser la
question suivante les dispositions
proposées permettront elles réellement
de protéger nos enfants contre les
prédateurs sexuels et d'en finir avec
l'impunité des agresseurs je n'en étais
pas convaincu aujourd'hui je me félicite
que vous permettiez à cette proposition
doit d'atteindre pleinement cet objectif
c'est une étape majeure qui est franchie
la prévention et la formation doivent
désormais s'additionner aux droits pour
aider à éradiquer ces violences
inacceptables
je vous remercie bien merci chers
collègues et la parole est maintenant à
marie pierre de la gontrie pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre
madame la rapporteure monsieur le
président la commission des lois mes
chers collègues je suis très débuté
mandat intervention au nom de mon groupe
par un hommage un hommage aux victimes
qui ont eu l'énergie et le courage de
parler un hommage aux associations qui
se sont battus depuis tant d'années un
hommage aux parlementaires
annie billon mais aussi laurence
rossignol
michel meunier isabelle santiago et donc
souligner que parfois cette société
civile que l'on désigne deux parcs de
termes parfois un peu péjoratif a fait
que la société a bougé et a fait que
nous parlementaires engagés depuis
longtemps sur ces sujets avons pu être
soutenu pour faire avancer cette cause
mais le combat a été long et y compris
dans cet hémicycle n'a pas toujours été
entendu nous avons débattu un nombre de
fois incalculable de ce sujet depuis que
je suis élu
c'est à dire 2017 plusieurs propositions
de loi projet de loi au cours duquel des
propositions ont été faites
y compris par les socialistes y compris
sur ce texte il y à peu le 21 janvier
nous avons proposé le seuil d'âge à 15
ans rejeté
nous avons proposé l'inceste interdit à
18 ans rejeté
nous avons proposé la prescription dit
glissante qui a été accepté ici avec un
intérêt manifesté par le garde des
sceaux qui a indiqué à ce moment là que
il souhaitait y retravailler si je
souligne cela c'est parce qu'il faut
beaucoup de d'obstination lorsqu'on est
parlementaire nous ne manquons pas mais
que pendant ce temps les victimes ne
sont pas protégés et que nous pouvons
voir les choses positivement
il a donc fallu que les semaines passent
pour que au final chacun se rende à la
raison et décide de soutenir les
propositions qui furent les nôtres
donc soyons optimistes ou plutôt positif
et notons les progrès accomplis ils sont
incontestables un grand nombre de
mesures doivent être retenue est saluée
mais plusieurs nous pose problème
la première concerne la question de
l'écart d'âge l'écart d'âge de cinq ans
baptisé close roméo et juliette
permettant de qualifier deux amours
adolescentes les relations sexuelles
entre un jeune de 19 ans et un jeune 14
ans tout cela va être une brèche
insupportable face à la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles sur mineures dont
nous voulons tous être les porteurs et
donc nous proposons la suppression de
cette notion la deuxième difficulté que
nous constatons c'est la notion d'
autorité de droit ou de fait
je pense qu'il ya une confusion sur ce
sujet l'inceste n'est pas un crime de
pouvoir l'inceste est un interdit
anthropologique et donc il n'y a pas de
notion de pouvoir de droit ou de fait à
prendre en considération dès lors que
l'inceste doit être sanctionné
enfin vous avez évoqué monsieur le garde
des sceaux à juste titre le fait que le
texte désormais protège davantage le
mineur en situation de prostitution
victimes mais vous l'avez précisé mineur
de 15 ans pourquoi de 15 ans et nous
proposons dans ce texte que ce soit tous
mineurs qu'ils soient protégés dans
cette situation car en quoi cela
serait-il moins grave que ce soit un
mineur de 16 ans qu'ils soient victimes
de prostitution et donc nous le
proposons ici nous avions proposé
d'autres compléments protection
obligation de signalement des sujets qui
ont été écartés grâce au bonheur de la
procédure parlementaire mais auquel nous
tenons vous le savez il se pose un sujet
par rapport à ce texte qui est sa
possibilité d'application par les
juridictions
nous avons désormais une législation
extraordinairement complexe face à un
sujet qu'il était déjà et j'ai tendance
à craindre la possibilité du coup de
s'insérer dans des failles ou dans des
imprécisions qui fasse que sur certaines
infractions les parquets mais aussi les
plaignants soit en difficulté pour
obtenir des poursuites
nous aurons bien sûr certains parquets
au fait parquet spécialisé mais tous les
parquets de france ne sont pas dans
cette situation et je vous le dis je
pense que de ce point de vue nous ne
faisons pas oeuvre de justice efficace
et donc sur l'ensemble de ces raisons
même si évidemment nous saluons de
progrès même si nous regrettons qu'il
ait fallu tant de textes pour arriver à
un résultat qui approche le positif mais
pour autant à ce stade
mon groupe n'a pas encore décidé
d'approuver ce texte
sauf à ce que les cards à ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure où que la
notion d' autorité de droit ou de fait
que j'évoquais également soit écarté
sous cette réserve
nous envisageons de ne pas voté pour ce
texte car nous souhaitons qu'ils
progressent encore y compris au cours
des échanges et de la commission mixte
paritaire
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à madame jacky dayraut midi
ou le groupe l'est républicain par don
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
madame la rapporteure mes chers
collègues nous sommes réunis une
nouvelle fois cet après midi pour
étudier la proposition de loi de notre
collègue annick billon après son examen
en première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale
nul besoin de souligner ici l'importance
du sujet tant l'actualité nous rappelle
presque chaque semaine que des enfants
ont souffert souffre et risquent de
souffrir encore si rien ne change c'est
l'honneur du sénat que d'avoir mis à
l'agenda politique
au travers de cette ppl la question
d'une révision de notre droit en matière
de crimes sexuels sur mineurs nous en
avons collectivement fait le constat la
dernière réforme date certes de 2018
elle ne résout pourtant autant elle ne
résout pour autant pas l'ensemble des
problèmes que la libération de la parole
des victimes et la libération non moins
importante de notre écoute a contribué à
mettre au coeur des priorités politiques
les débats en première lecture ont été
riches et je crois que l avec
parlementaire a rempli son office
preuve en est le gouvernement a décidé
de reprendre le texte issu du sénat pour
faire aboutir la réforme et il nous faut
le souligner nous le savons l'assemblée
nationale a décidé de fixer le seuil de
non consentement à un rapport sexuel
avec un mineur à 15 ans contre 13 en
proposer au sénat nous ne nous
opposerons pas à ce nouveau seuil
même si les retours du terrain nous font
craindre une application juridique plus
compliqué pour les professionnels
concernés
je tiens ici à rappeler que le sénat
contrairement aux mauvaises politiques
suscitées lors du vote du premier texte
en lecture il avait décidé de fixer le
seuil de non consentement à 13 ans que
dans le but d'éviter une censure du
conseil constitutionnel nous avons juger
en conscience qu'une telle censure
aurait constitué un signal extrêmement
déplorable pour les victimes en attente
d'un cadre plus protecteurs
l'introduction lors de la navette
la clause dite roméo et juliette doit
permettre d'éviter une telle censure
il s'agit de prendre en compte dans
notre droit
ce qui peut être qualifié d'amours
adolescentes caractérisée par un faible
écart d'âge entre une personne mineure
et une personne majeure avec l'adoption
de ce texte les choses seront donc clair
toute relation sexuelle entre un majeur
et un mineur de moins de 15 ans sera
considéré comme un viol dans le cadre
d'une relation intrafamiliales toute
relation avec un mineur commis par un
proche ayant une autorité de droit ou de
fait sera désormais qualifiée de vol
incestueux le débat parlementaire n'a
pas seulement permis de modifier les
curseurs d'âge si important soit-il sur
notre initiative et avec le travail de
l'assemblée
il a également permis de préciser notre
droit en le rendant plus proche de la
réalité que vivent encore de trop
nombreuses victimes
c'est ainsi que nous avons introduit dès
la première lecture au sénat le sujet de
la prescription glissante pour les cas
de crimes sériels l'assemblée s'en est
emparé et je me réjouis que la
disposition était été conservés c'est
également le sénat qui a proposé
l'introduction des rapports
buccogénitaux dans la définition légale
du viol réparant en ce sens
un oubli dommageable de notre droit à
l'initiative de notre rapporteur marie
mercier
la commission des lois a amélioré le
texte en modifiant par exemple la
nouvelle infraction pénale
introduite à l'assemblée nationale
visant à réprimer le fait pour un majeur
de demander à un mineur l'envoi d'imagés
pornographiques de lui-même
notre commission des lois a fait le soin
d'élargir la protection des mineurs en
prévoyant que cette nouvelle infraction
concerne l'ensemble des mineurs et non
les seuls mineurs de moins de 15 ans de
la même manière nous avons fait le choix
en commission d'élargir la protection
garantie aux mineurs dans
les caddies de ce extorsion ce délit qui
consiste pour un majeur à extorquer la
diffusion ou la transmission d'image
vidéo ou représentations à caractère
pornographique d'un mineur permettra de
protéger l'ensemble des mineurs et non
les seuls mineurs de moins de 15 ans la
peine sera quant à elle a gravé si les
faits sont commis à l'encontre d'un
mineur de 15 ans ou en bande organisée
mes chers collègues le texte qui nous
revient au sénat en deuxième lecture est
je le crois un texte d'équilibré adaptée
aux enjeux de notre temps
ce sujet difficile peut demain concerner
chacun de nos enfants ne nous faisons
pas d'illusions la réponse pénale que
nous organisons aujourd'hui est certes
un élément essentiel de la lutte contre
les crimes sexuels commis sur les
mineurs
elles n'en constituent pourtant qu'une
partie le reste du travail est complexe
et doit mobiliser l'ensemble de la
société dans les milieux associatifs
auprès des familles dans les écoles les
collèges et les lycées
sans oublier internet il constitue sans
aucun doute le grand enjeu de demain à
la place qui est la nôtre dans cet
hémicycle
nous avons fait notre devoir et je crois
que nous pouvons collectivement en être
fier l'unanimité qui a prévalu en
première lecture tant au sénat qu'à
l'assemblée nous oblige le travail se
poursuit cet après-midi nous le devons à
toutes les victimes aussi nombreuses
familles brisées et à la société toute
entière qui attend de nous des actes
forts ce vous remercie merci merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant
madame valérie boyer pour les
républicains
monsieur le ministre
madame le rapporteur madame l'auteur du
texte mes chers collègues combattre les
violences notamment sexuelles face aux
mineurs c'est s'attaquer à des cases
intolérable de violations d'atteinte à
la personne de l'enfant à leur innocence
à leur intégrité physique et mentale ces
actes abjects sont autant de traumatisme
pour ses jeunes vies qu'il faut enlever
d'autres moscou même très bien il est
remonté
c'est ainsi que prend la vie d'un nombre
important de personnes des centaines de
milliers peut-être même plus dans notre
seul pays
cette vie a été abîmée gâcher au ruinés
par des personnes qui se devait au
contraire de protéger et de faire
grandir
rappelons selon un sondage que près de
la moitié des victimes de viols dans
l'enfance aurait fait par la suite une
tentative de suicide
nous le dirons jamais assez les viols
sont une honte pour notre pays mais plus
largement pour toutes les nations de ce
monde qui les accepte et qu'il ne les
punissent pas en france environ 2
enfants par classe sont victimes
d'inceste ou de pédocriminalité 81% des
violences sexuelles commencé avant 18
ans la première agression souvenant en
moyenne à 9 ans au moment du cm1 dans
94% des cas elles sont commises par des
proches
depuis de nombreuses années une prise de
conscience collective s'est opérée grâce
aux professionnels de la prévention de
la santé de la répression
grâce aussi une évolution des mentalités
où il n'est plus interdite de tout
interdire au contraire il est même
parfois recommandé d'interdire ce qui
doit l'être
je veux les remercier je veux saluer
leur travail notamment celui des
associations je veux saluer l'engagement
des professionnels
je pense ici à ernestine ronai et au
juge edouard durant pour le hce à
françoise laborde ou encore muriel
salmona et tant d'autres qui ont
réveillé les consciences
les récents mouvements nobilise à sion
notamment avec le hashtag me toisait
sont générés de un nombre considérable
de témoignages dénonçant ces drames
désormais les violences sexuelles ne
sont plus tu dans le secret d'une
famille d'une entreprise désormais elles
ne sont plus minimisé et nous avons tous
pris en compte l'impact traumatique de
ces violences la parole des victimes
s'est libéré et
ja ne doit l'arrêter et rien ne doit
arrêter ce mouvement selon le juge
edward durant le passage à l'acte de la
tune est une perversion du besoin
affectif de l'enfant
en aucun cas un enfant ne peut être
consentant à une relation sexuelle
et c'est bien que ce texte le 10 c'est
pourquoi il était important que le
parlement soit au rendez vous nous le
devons au nom des plus de 165 mille
enfants violées chaque année trois
minutes un abus sexuels et ce sont des
années de graves conséquences sur la vie
d'un enfant
j'ai aussi la conviction depuis
plusieurs années que la lutte contre les
violences physiques et sexuelles
dépassent nos égos et nos clivages
je suis fier que cette loi puisse
constituer un remarquable pas en avant
et je pense que nous pouvons être tous
hier collectivement d'y avoir contribué
sur tous les bancs de cette assemblée
c'est la preuve que le bicamérisme est
important et je veux saluer le travail
de la présidente annick billon qui a eu
l'initiative de ce texte que nous
apprêtons à voter je le crois et je
l'espère unanimement
merci beaucoup madame la présidente de
l'adf que ce soit au sénat puis à
l'assemblée nationale grâce à nos débats
le texte a évolué c'est profondément
enrichi pour autant à titre personnel je
reste réservé sur l'infraction autonome
je crois toujours que nous devons
insister sur l'absence de contrainte et
non l'absence de consentement car seul
l'auteur est responsable de ses actes et
jamais un enfant ne peut consentir une
seconde voie était constitutionnelle en
respectant le principe de présomption
d'innocence du pas le principe d'égalité
devant la loi d'autre part je
m'interroge aussi sur l'institution d'un
écart d'âge de cinq ans permettant de ne
pas criminaliser les amours adolescentes
je crois que cette clause de cinq ans
telle qu'elle est proposée aujourd'hui
crée en effet une entorse au principe
que nous tentons de défendre malgré ces
réserves je suis convaincu que le texte
que nous devons voter va dans le bon
sens
il répond au prix qu'aux préoccupations
exprimées tant par le sénat que par
l'assemblée nationale
nos travaux ont permis de dégager un
consensus sur un certain nombre de
principes
je me félicite par exemple de l'adoption
de notre amendement avec michel sapin
qui vise à élargir la liste des
infractions entraînant une inscription
dans le fichier judiciaire des auteurs
d'infractions sexuelles et violente de
l'adoption de cet amendement du groupe
écologiste concernant les actes
bucco-génitaux du groupe socialiste sur
la définit
duviol ne nous avance et bien sûr sur la
prescription et je pense aux avancées
portées à l'assemblée nationale aussi à
l'instauration d'un seuil d'âge de 15
ans c'est l'âge que j'ai toujours
défendue il était important que la
justice se focalise sur l'agresseur et
non plus sur le comportement de la
victime
il est possible qu'il est utilisé la
violence la menace ou la surprise mais
il ya une certitude
l'enfant a toujours été contraints et
l'enfant ne peut jamais consentir je
salue également l'institution d'un seuil
d'âge a 18 ans quand d'inceste assimi
chers collègues je vous invite mais je
sais que tous ici le feront à soutenir
unanimement ce texte
albert einstein disait le monde ne sera
pas détruit par ceux qui font le mal
mais par ceux qui les regardent sans
rien faire je pense que là nous avons
tous collectivement essayé d'agir
c'est pourquoi je vous dis aujourd'hui
avec force avec détermination avec
conviction
car être engagé dans la vie publique
c'est avant tout défendre des
convictions et si vous me permettez
monsieur le ministre
avec passion et émotion parce que c'est
ça aussi qui nous anime et donc je crois
que nous pouvons être heureux
aujourd'hui en ce 25 mars 2001 de porter
ce message ensemble unissant nos efforts
pour les victimes pour les enfants qui
espère de nous et nous oublie donc long
et de ses victimes qui je le sais nous
regardent et qui aujourd'hui se sent
probablement moins seul et surtout
écoutés et compris
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
donc la discussion générale est close je
crois que le ministre ne veut pas à
parler à ce stade donc avant de passer à
la discussion du texte de la commission
je vais suspendre la séance avant de
permettre à la commission de se réunir
sur les amendements qui ont été déposées
en début d'après midi
monsieur le président de combien de
temps estimez-vous avoir besoin monsieur
le président
vingtaine de minutes s'il vous plaît
bien donc la séance est suspendue
elle sera reprise à 17h40
[Musique]